just imagine being this close again
[Applause]
this wasn't pre pandemic this is right
now
on the isle of man we do have to
remember how lucky we are over here we
are
pretty much going to get to live a
normal life we're going to get back to
doing
school get back to doing all our
activities
the movit dance studio might not have
survived without this newfound freedom
it's just great having the opportunity
to teach properly without
um guidelines on the floor and masks and
everything else so
the kids when they first just walked in
for the first time were squealing we
were squealing
this self-governing island in the irish
sea did well containing the virus last
year
but then had to have a tough january
lockdown
the good news is that it's worked so the
85 000 residents
can meet mix and even do this again
and when you have freedom it is worth
protecting
the way they're going to maintain it is
to keep the borders closed to
non-islanders so this
the waterfront in liverpool is about as
close as we can get to the island today
the chief minister told us they can't be
complacent
we've gone for total elimination of
covert on our island rather than living
with it
that enables us to have all these
freedoms but
you know we had to be pretty tough in
the early days to be when we drove it
off the island
we didn't know where it was so we had to
have a tough lockdown but
as a result of that our people have a
normal life here
that means walking football is back too
because
almost everyone here followed the rules
they've been people who've been
sent to prison for four weeks for six
weeks of flouting the rules
but i think people here realize it was
necessary in order to to get this
freedom
that we've got now the the government
here closed it very quickly i know it
restricted movement but heck
you know we haven't had the problems by
any comparison to what's going on in the
uk
if you head north south east or west
from here you reach a different nation
of the uk
under lockdown the manx people are on
their own
the envy of the british isles tom
parmenter
sky news not on the isle of man